he is the creator as well as the host of
pro football talk right here on nbc
sports on peacock friend mike florio
back here on the show how are you mike
rich i'm doing great buddy how are you
i am doing well the story of week one
is what you know it's funny i heard
your options for the poll question teams
that should be most panicked browns
cowboys equals vikings
i'll tell you what i am stunned that
more isn't being said
about what the arizona cardinals did to
the san francisco 49ers defending
division champions defending conference
champions of one seed a year ago
to go in there and to outscore the 49ers
in their own building to start the
season that was a stunner to me and i
watched that game yesterday
kyler murray is a superstar and
i'd say jimmy garoppolo to quote a line
from the longest yard remake is half a
star at this point
so it's looking very good for the
cardinals
and i think the 49ers i'm going to go
off the board and say the 49ers should
be the most panicked after week one well
let me let me do a little bit of
pushback counselor
um the fact that um debo samuel is not
out there
neither was ayuk and then the minute
that uh buddha baker
uh took out um kittle he didn't have a
catch the rest of the day
and he's got a knee problem right now
that said i do love kyla murray and
deandre hopkins
is definitely out to show uh the texans
made the wrong
maneuver so i guess that would be my
response to that
well i agree with you there but here's
the thing george kittle's knee injury
happened on a proverbial or literal
hospital ball thrown by jimmy garoppolo
on a screen pass where
it just sailed up over kittle's head
kittle jumped up for it exposing his
knee to that contact i mean garoppolo
caused that injury
and garoppolo when he completed passes
didn't look accurate and then the last
drive of the game when they had a chance
to win
rich there were two different plays
where the best
example or comparison i can come up with
is it's a dad throwing a candy bar to
two kids and he really doesn't care
which one gets it
and he did that twice whereas just toss
the ball up there's two guys there one
from one team one from the other
team and hey whoever gets it gets it and
that's just not the way to inspire the
confidence of kyle shanahan and to keep
jimmy garoppolo in the good graces
that's not the way they wanted to see
him
respond to the way last season ended and
i was stunned
to see the contrast between kyler murray
who just
has it all speed agility and awareness
in a combination i have never before
witnessed
and to see that on the same field with
garoppolo i'd be very depressed
right now if i was a 49ers fan i said
the cardinals were my sleeper team of
the nfc
um even though you know obviously they
they have a lot of stars on it i thought
that they could make a serious run
in their division i definitely think
they're making the playoffs and
i was glad to see a week one result
result that might
make me sound uh remotely smart but that
that's the toughest division in football
right wouldn't you say
nfc west absolutely and here's the thing
with three wild cards now i mean in one
of these years if they keep reshuffling
the deck and playing these seasons
indefinitely
there's gonna be four teams that come
out of one division and when you look at
that nfc west top to bottom
i wouldn't rule it out in the first year
of three wild card teams i mean it would
be crazy
and it would be a long shot but we've
seen three teams come from one division
why not have that fourth team depending
upon what your cross pollination is and
i think they play all the teams of the
afc east
and the nfc east that lets them fatten
up their record with eight games half
their schedule
they are feasting on lesser opponents
except for the patriots obviously
and and it could put them in position
where you could get
three maybe four teams out of the nfc
west that's how good it is yeah i know
and
and seattle uh you you know the way that
they played and looked you could make a
case atlanta should be on our poll
question as well we only have four
thanks to the uh the twitter beast that
we try to feed every single day
mike florio here on the on the rich
eisen show so what about uh
what about last night what'd you take
out of last night's double dip
mike you know it's funny rich the early
game
had a double-digit score and it was a
hell of a lot closer than that
the late game had a two-point margin and
it felt like the titans beat him by 20.
it just shows you how
easily a game when you see that final
score
fails to tell the story of what really
happened uh the giants were were in
business at 16 to 10 they had this
ridiculously long drive and then here
comes bud dupree and the ball pops up in
the air
and the steelers get it and they drive
down and get a field goal to turn a six
point
margin into a nine point margin three
and out by the giants
touchdown by the steelers and they it's
game over just like that when it could
have been 17-16 going into the fourth
quarter
uh so i i i thought the giants acquitted
themselves
very well in the first game of the joe
judge era and for the titans
they look like you know ryan tannehill
looks different to me
i don't know whether it's his
performance from last year whether it's
he's going to make more over the next
four years than patrick mahomes or
deshaun watson under his contract and
that gives him confidence
he just seems like a more confident guy
but the titans should not
have had to kick a field goal with 17
seconds left to win that game
they should have won that game going
away mike florio of pro football
talk and then every single day pro
football talk live is what kicks off
nbc sports on peacock uh standalone
channel that we're thrilled to be part
of
uh right here on the rich eisen show um
the
teams that you had making the super bowl
or which what was your pre-season
prediction now that you're joining us
here
rich i get asked all the time what do
you root for well
i when you own a media company you root
for a good story that people are going
to find compelling and there's no more
compelling story than belichick versus
brady in the super bowl
and so i went with buccaneers and
patriots and obviously after one week i
feel good about half of it and not so
good about the other half but
they got 15 more games to go the
buccaneers were drawing the saints in
new orleans at some point this year
let's just
flush that one down the toilet and move
on to the next 15 games but
you know i'm rooting for that it's it's
chaos
in a controlled way it would be awesome
and
i'm not ready to write off the
buccaneers and i'm not ready to
crown the patriots either because they
got to keep cam newton healthy and if he
keeps running like he did week one
they're gonna have a hard time keeping
him healthy well i mean
you could take a look at the bucks
saints game and say the following
um and you may this this this is not
brady apology
or um or soft pedaling anything
but um the bucks did give
the saints uh a possession
on special teams where they just let a
ball bounce i mean it was
on a kickoff that was dreadful and then
a pick six
and then a miscommunication between
evans and brady led to another
interception
it's very difficult to win a football
game period when you're
uh doing that let alone against brees
and alvin camaro
uh now fully paid and you know
i think you can just chalk it up to
that's just one week and
and the bucks are still deep and
talented the the patriots
um that was just the latest example of
belichick and certainly mcdaniels
taking what they have and making the
most out of it and we'll see if they
switch it up against seattle on the the
upcoming sunday night game on nbc
but it was really just great seeing cam
out there smiling and doing his thing
like it was
uh the cam of old mike and rich here's
what happened it was ten years ago when
josh mcdaniels was the head coach of the
denver broncos traded back into round
one to get tim tebow right
developed an offense for tebow never got
to use it because he got fired before
tebow became the starter
but that was the offense denver used in
2011 when tebow mania ran wild and
that's the offense they're using now in
new england
with a quarterback who all due respect
to tim tebow is dramatically better
you know they've been they've been
holding that for 10 years you're never
going to use that offense with tom brady
now you got a guy you're going to use
that offense with i mean bill belichick
explained it yesterday
you cater the offense to who you have
that's good coaching
now they have cam newton they have a cam
newton offense and
and watch out and what a game for sunday
night i mean i'm not that gratuitously
promoted
doesn't need promotion russell wilson
and cam newton are you kidding me
well another thing too you couldn't if
you want to talk about seattle as well
as the the afc east
the through line is jamal adams and how
it's amazing how
uh pete carroll is like laughing about
adam's freelancing
and uh you know and dan quinn's
basically saying we saw things out of
the defense that
you know we've never really seen on the
back end of the defense and jamal adams
is the difference and that's exactly why
he got benched in new york
it's insane to me and then that jets
team comes out and lays a total leg
uh against the bills team for whom i
think the afc east is still the division
i kind of give both of you
those subject matters for you to chew on
right there and here's the thing about
jamal adams i talked to russell wilson
after the game
you know russell is always going to be a
team guy he's always going to praise his
teammates that's the way he is we've
been hearing it for nine seasons now but
when i asked him about jamal adams
it changed right it was different he
stopped
and he started rattling off one word
after another i got my notes here
leadership energy focus discipline
execution hall of fame championship
player
and i mean each word had an exclamation
point on the end of it he loves this guy
and adams loves being with uh with
russell wilson and company like uh adam
said after the game it's nice to be on
an offense that can score 38 points
you can't blame him for firing shots
like that you just can't
you can't blame him for doing that you
know at some point he's got to let it go
and just declare himself to victor and
move on
but with the jets on the schedule in
week 14 i think it is i guess it's going
to be hard for him to do it if they
weren't on the schedule this year to be
different
but this is that one in four years where
they cross paths and
so he's not going to quit thinking about
the jets because every time he glances
at the schedule he's going to see that
date in december
and i think there's a new hashtag in
this world for the
seahawks offense hashtag let russ cook i
love that concept
i love it it's time it's time with dk
metcalf and
tyler lockett and greg olsen and um
i think it's you know sky's the limit
you should at least get an mvp vote this
year let's put it that way well
absolutely here's the thing
rich we had russell wilson on set with
us chris sims and i at the super bowl
and
and he said then and he said it in his
always very positive way and you never
can quite
tell when russell wilson's saying
something that's remotely controversial
but he said
i'd i'd like the offense to treat
you know the rest of the game like we
tend to treat it in the fourth quarter
when we need to score points let's have
a greater sense of urgency
let's make it happen he's since said
that again publicly
and and and you know this drives
seahawks fans crazy but the reality is
if they don't hashtag let russ cook
they're going to have a problem
with russell because he's every bit as
good as the best quarterbacks in the nfl
and he wants to have the opportunity to
show it not to be a show-off
but when you have this ferrari you're
paying the guy 35 million a year
you take it out and you drive it around
at least close to the speed limit and i
think
that was the challenge for the seahawks
this year and so far so good
and whatever game plan they put together
last week that should embolden them
to to do the same kind of thing week in
and week out and and let him do his
thing because he really is
every bit as good as the best guys it's
just the flare isn't there you know with
patrick mahomes there's always that
element
of his hair's on fire with russell
wilson it's so efficient
and it's more like a cobra strike you
don't realize what he just did until it
happens
and and the end result's the same but
there's just something about that that
entertainment value you know the the are
you not entertained
i mean russell wilson does it too
quickly for us to even fully appreciate
it and uh we're gonna get to see more
opportunities
for him to do things that we'll
appreciate this year because uh
he already got it done and i think
they're going to keep doing it and yeah
maybe he finally gets an mvp vote this
year
because he wants to do it too mike um
i'm going to put this up on the screen
when uh he and his wife had a beautiful
new baby boy
um i tweeted out to celebrate the birth
of his new baby boy
all of at dangerous wilson and offensive
coordinators chipped in and got him his
own third and eight
and it was liked by russell wilson
[Laughter]
i got a like out of him for that he
wants it man
he wants it mike he wants it well look
he's he's he's getting toward the
midpoint of his career he said multiple
times he wants to play until he's
45 he turns 32 i think in december and
you you start to you know with each
passing year as you see
what patrick mahomes has in front of him
you see what lamar jackson's doing you
know that the bar is tom brady with six
here you are in year nine with one super
bowl championship
and one appearance you know at what
point do you skew
in the direction of aaron rodgers all do
respect aaron rodgers but he's got one
for his career
or tom brady who's got six and at some
point you've got to break out of that
mold and i think he wants to break out
of it right now
mike florio a couple more minutes left
with mike florio pro football talk and
pro football
talk live as well as pft pm which i want
to get to as well
uh which is a part of our nbc sports on
peacock
stream that we're we're on right now um
out of the vast amounts of opinions that
you've had um
on any of the formats that you uh
opinionate
uh which is the one prior to week one
that you would take back post week one
even though you know it's a knee-jerk
week-to-week league
what do you would you do but we don't
have enough hopefully you have a hard
break coming soon so i don't have to
really embarrass myself no plenty of
them i'll give you i'll give you i'll
give you i'll give you one as a for
instance so you can roll the decks
through your mind mine would be
saying the vikings are winning the nfc
north i would take that one that's what
i was going to say okay and
here's here's my take well i was wrong
about the packers because i thought
you know with the jordan love draft pick
they're telling the world we're taking a
step back
in the hopes of rebuilding something
that can compete with the 49ers after
getting their asses kicked
twice last year by the 49ers i think
they looked in the mirror and said we
got to develop an offense like what the
49ers have
and that's why they did what they did in
the draft and i thought the vikings
would still have enough to to maneuver
but
good lord to give up 43 points at home
now it shows you the value of having
fans especially to a defense that relies
on a pass rush
but that's the most points the vikings
have ever given up in a season opening
game in their 60 year history
and my big picture psychological concern
for the vikings is this
after beating the saints in the playoffs
they got their butts kicked by the 49ers
but
the playoff win in the wild card round
got kirk cousins a new contract mike
zimmer a new contract rick spielman a
new contract
and most recently dalvin cook a new
contract when you throw in everything
that's going on with the pandemic
no fans in minnesota it's a different
kind of year
it's easier to look at this as something
that at some level is viewed as kind of
a scholarship year
and it's not as critical the heat's not
on and based on what i saw
on sunday it fits that narrative because
you don't let the packers come in
and wipe the floor with you in your own
building like that and just
score it well they got dom capers on
their coaching staff rich he was the
defensive coordinator of the packers
if he doesn't have an answer for how to
slow down a guy he's seen it practice
for years
it's it's either it's either very bad
news for anyone who has to deal with the
packers or very bad news for anybody who
has a vested interest in the vikings
doing well
so you're a legal expert turned football
expert
and now like all of us uh hopefully a
public health expert what's
what's the next what are you hearing
from the nfl about the the holding your
breath
moment between now and when to know how
week one
worked out with all the crossing of
vectors with everybody
with cohen well rich i think if they do
the testing on a daily basis and i'm
very glad the nfl
is planning to test on a daily basis for
the rest of the season they haven't
announced that yet all they've said is
until further notice
i'm told they're going to do it all
season long they're happy that the union
pushed for daily testing the league
wanted to do it three times a week
but i was told last week what happened
is having this routine this rhythm every
day
test test test that has helped keep
players accountable
so let's see with the aftermath of
traveling leaving the mini bubble is as
the week unfolds will there be an
outbreak anywhere
and then the bigger question in my mind
when teams fall out of contention and i
think the league is thinking of this as
well
when teams fall out of contention will
their players specifically their young
players lose their focus and not care as
much
anymore and they need to because if
games get wiped out
they lose their game checks but that's
going to be the challenge we get in
november and december
and when there's that handful of teams
that we know has done
will their players continue to stay
focused through the end of the run so i
think that's the
the realistic concern now they want the
coaches to wear the masks and whatnot
there could be some punishments
if teams and coaches and people on the
sidelines fail
to comply coming up this week but you
know it's more about
the testing it's more about the travel
and also about making sure that the
young players continue to do smart
things and not put themselves in
situations where they may
catch the virus yeah i mean because the
word is before we came on the air today
that uh
you know our friend jeff pass and our
colleague at espn
uh covering baseball is that baseball is
going to bubble up for the playoffs you
hearing anything like that
uh that maybe there's a bubble up in the
i-4 corridor
uh orlando tampo where the super bowl is
going to be you hear any conversation
about that for january as we're right
here right now
started rich the nfl was doing weekly
conference calls with troy vincent the
executive vp of football operations
and alan sills the chief medical officer
and
troy troy said that that the competition
committee
had mentioned the possibility of a
postseason bubble but
i think it's a practical matter the
teams are going to be more likely to
bubble up the teams are more
likely to say to their families look
we're all going to stay at a hotel until
the run's over
whenever it may be so i don't think
you're going to need a formal bubble
because i think informally the teams
that are still alive that's that's the
point you know it's one thing to say in
september hey honey i'm living in a
hotel
all year long sorry i'm not going to be
around for the next four months it's
another thing when january rolls around
to say we got three or four games left
and and we're going to hunker down and
we're going to stay together
and maybe i'll be home this weekend
maybe i'll see you in early february but
i think it's more likely that that's
what the teams will do
okay last one for you mike tell me about
pft pm
that's uh at the end of the if you will
um nbc sports on peacock daily rainbow
that you start
yeah and here's here's sometimes you
gotta be careful what you wish for rich
i've learned that lesson way too many
times in life pftpm
was a very loose do it whenever i feel
like doing it
afternoon podcast if i was in the mood
to do it i'd slip on the isdn or i turn
on the camera and i'd do it
now it's an obligation now it's every
day for one hour not that i'm
complaining
but you got to build it into the rhythm
of your day
i'd rather do three hours in a row like
you instead of two and then a nine hour
break for the next one
but it's a lot of fun it's a looser feel
it's
end of the day you know kind of a happy
hour vibe not that i plan on
literally treating it like happy hour
but shereen williams is going to be with
me three days a week
and we're going to have our our picks
against the spread on thursdays and
it goes so fast that's the thing when
you break it up into two and one
that that last one nine hours later just
flies by and we had a lot of fun
yesterday and we'll do it again today
after you're done and then brother from
another that's right with michael hawley
and mike smith and then we wrap up the
day and uh do it all over again tomorrow
well whenever you need me on uh on pm
am's a little too early for me
out here on the west coast uh uh you
know uh i'm i'm i'm there for you
um i'll i'll bring the drinks uh you
know i'll bring the drinks for the pm
pft pm all right okay good deal you got
it you can't spell florida without that
you got it you can't spell floria
without i or mike without me but he's a
team player
he's doing the fact he's doing the front
and the back thank you very much
thanks thanks mike you're the man i
appreciate this mike florio
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here